protesters in cities and towns across
Ethiopia's and mahara region have
rallied in support of their local forces
for five days in a row they want the
federal government to abandon its plans
to integrate their Regional Fighters
into the National military or police
violence near amhara's border of Tigre
forced some areas to impose curfews and
restrict public transport
they go under the historic town of
gonder which is a UNESCO recognized town
has called for curfew tried trying to
end this public defense against the
Ethiopian government that insists there
won't be any kind of compromise in terms
of ending the spatial forces in which
the amhara regions as well as other
regions have benefited from in the past
the plan will apply to 11 regions which
have their own fighting groups and use
their own languages
the government of prime minister ABI
Ahmed says it's critical for the
national Unity of Ethiopia
but it's not been well received in
anhara whose Regional forces supported
the federal army in its two-year
conflict with Rebels into gray that
began in 2020. since then amhara leaders
have accused the federal government of
ignoring attacks on ethnic amharas
living in the neighboring oromia region
they fear dissolving their Regional
forces will leave them vulnerable to
further attacks and prevent them from
defending themselves Barbara angupa Al
Jazeera
live now to Charlotte North Carolina to
wadro's turfi who is Chairman of the
amhara Association of America good to
have you with us sir why is there so
much anger and frustration in amhara
over what the federal government wants
to do here
Adrian thank you for uh having me on
your program today
um it's very simple at the beginning of
April the regime of prime minister ABI
Ahmed Ali and the Oromo ruling branch of
the prosperity party began a new wave of
attacks against the amhara people to
dissolve the amhara regional Special
Forces which are critical to maintaining
peace and Security in the amhara region
this unprecedented illegal and
unilateral disarmament of the abhara
regional Special Forces will leave
millions of amharas in the first list
and also helpless this is very important
here yeah but but why can't the the
amhara Special Forces if they're
absorbed into a national Army still
protect amhara as part of Ethiopia's
National Army
that's a question
trust in the Prime Minister ABI Ahmed
Ali the purpose for disarming is really
dissolving and really not incorporating
incorporating them into the Ethiopian
military it is really to disarm and
dissolve
um and the purpose behind it is to
render amhara people defenseless again
and also allow the re-annexation of
ancestral amhara lands uh back into the
tplf that is why many amhara's across
the region have been protesting Millions
uh for the past four days and
unfortunately and and one thing also
that is clear is that the Ohio region
has the power within the Constitution to
also establish Regional forces uh prime
minister ABI Ahmed Ali did this without
communicating to the amhara people
explaining the reasons behind it this is
just a unilateral and an illegal move by
the uh by prime minister ABI Ahmed Ali
at a time when the country no longer the
needs this this level of instability
is causing instability again within the
country
um how
dangerous is the situation then could
could this turn into a situation where
uh I'm had our regional forces are
fighting with the national Army could
could civil Strife ensue
it's it's already started they have been
protest for four days straight across
the entire region millions of people
have come out to the streets the
Ethiopian military has
um opened live fire against peaceful
protesters they have been reports of
clashes in North one low and also in the
central part of the country we're
concerned that the situation is going to
get out of hand and that's why we are
pleading with the International
Community to quickly step in and condemn
the actions of prime minister ABI Ahmed
Ali and his administration and to impose
targeted sanctions against prime
minister
and also General
who are responsible for this if this
does not happen if the International
Community does not quickly step in we
are very concerned that not only would
this further destabilize the region but
the country the Horn of Africa and the
entire continent of Africa as well we're
talking about a country that is five
times the size of of Syria we saw what
happens Syria there's about 115 million
people in Ethiopia and this is really
unnecessary
um in the past few weeks
several journalists have been arrested
already
uh including mascara that was arrested
yesterday this is her third time this
year that she has been arrested
um uh Civic uh Civic leaders uh youth
leaders
um they're just being abducted by by uh
by Ethiopia security Personnel
um without any provocation at all and so
that's why we're really asking the
International Community to quickly step
in okay for four days millions of people
have been protesting in addition to
what's happening within the amhara
region uh the Prime Minister ABI Ahmed
Ali's regime has been demolishing the
homes
um of uh amaras in addisawa in the
capital itself as a result thousands of
amaras have been made homeless this is
incredible and this is unprecedented all
right so we're gonna have to edit that
many thanks indeed for being with us
in North Carolina